let's go next to our caller from the six
one nine area code who's calling today
from six one nine hey Steve what's up
yeah I'm watching all of this madness
unfold and you appear to be one of the
few reasonable voices still holding on
to relevant in my mind the question
everybody seems to be missing because
it's too terrifying to confront
objective reality is dead it's as dead
as Julius Caesar it's not coming back
it's not resting in peace and Donald
Trump totally understands this
he operates as Niall Arco tent
I hope you've read much HP Lovecraft I
have HP Lovecraft who writes about scary
other-dimensional forces has a character
not a lot so tell who is he he shows up
when your planet has gone insane when
you're teetering on the abyss
he shows up and he is designed to be a
carnival barker showman who can get you
to accept the fact that objectivity and
sanity will never be seen again and
Donald Trump perfectly personifies this
anybody who ignores it does so at their
peddle because there is nothing to
support them no what I think is
interesting I basically agree with you I
think what's important to understand is
you don't see large groups of people
saying the facts don't matter what you
see is they just create and believe
their own facts and insulate themselves
from anything else so and that is
arguably even more dangerous because now
the mechanism through which we figure
out what is true and what is not that's
what becomes irrelevant and people don't
know it people are presented with this
information online and even if it
strikes them as maybe wrong they don't
have the tools to determine for
themselves whether something is true or
false that's the real crisis here
yes and as Harry Nielsen once said a
point in every direction is the same is
no point at all right well this is more
like yeah this is more like Aldous
Huxley's brave new world
we're in 1984 they controlled which
books people could read books were burnt
you know Fahrenheit 451 they burned
books so on and so forth in Aldous
Huxley's brave new world it's more like
it doesn't even really matter that we
don't need to bother trying to ban any
books because there's just so much stuff
out there nobody can tell what's worth
reading nobody can tell what's true let
them read whatever whatever books they
want we're just gonna flood things with
a sea of irrelevance and nobody will
know what the hell is going on yes and
the last thing I'll say here is that I
don't know if you've studied much on
simulation hypothesis mmm the top man
the big brain
II want loss etcetera even Richard
Dawkins has capitulated to this there's
no way to prove that we're not in a
simulation sure it's some kind of game
and the fact is all you evidence
suggests that we are in a game because
objectivity and the things that we used
to think are true are gone well I don't
know about that I don't know I don't
know about I don't know about the
evidence suggests we're in a simulation
but certainly I've read about the
theories you're discussing the idea
being if we're in a simulation that is
good enough that it is all-encompassing
and we have no way to test its limits
and to see outside of it we would never
be able to know for sure that we are in
a simulation it's sort of like the
Truman the movie The Truman Show with
Jim Carrey where he was in a run in a
life that was it was like a studio it
was a set at some point he saw glitches
in it and started to be able to
understand the concept of what's outside
the simulation if the simulation is good
and appeared not be able to tell all
right so the last thing I'll toss back
to you let you go the glitches
there's no other way to explain the
insanity that's unfolding in
institutional systems in the United
States and then the world more broadly
but everything happens first in United
States as you know the fact is is that
Donald Trump's success can only be
explained by the fact that we're in a
game he knows it no one else wants to
admit it well listen I think American
greats certainly become a game but I
don't know that it
proves that we are in a simulation in
the way that people like Elon Musk and
Richard Dawkins are suggesting but I
really appreciate the call and really
interesting stuff to think about as many
of you know I am super careful about
where we publish and distribute david
pakman show content it's a really
important decision that we make where do
we want our content to be we don't want
to spread ourselves too thin but we want
to make sure that we're taking advantage
of good platforms where our content
could do well and over the last couple
of months I've been testing publishing
our content to a platform called library
that's lbr why I've mentioned it once or
twice before and we are absolutely
loving it it's a fantastic platform
where our revenue as publishers does not
depend on some algorithm deciding
whether an ad should run before a video
or not in fact it's actually an ad-free
platform where our revenue is determined
by the number of people that watch our
videos and also by the tips that are
left for us in credits that are in
platform credits it's their own sort of
currency so to speak by viewers like you
and right now for people who sign up on
this platform it's completely free using
the link down in the video description
for every verified signup we get a
little bit of a credit and you also get
a credit of tips that you can then leave
on content that you like such as the
david pakman show content that we are
publishing so use the link down in the
video description
no algorithmic determinations about
whether we get to make money or we don't
get to make money or any of that stuff
all of our video content is being
published there use that link sign up
you'll get a credit will get a credit
and it's a beautiful thing and I'll
update you guys in a couple of weeks
about how it's going there's also a
contest that they're running
whoever can refer the most new users
gets a huge reward which would be a big
big boost to us so check it out link
down in the video description sign up
let me know what you think